>>> BENNY WILLIS HIRED
DOZEN LAWY
INVESTS FROM
TRUMP'S O SECRET
RAFFENBERGER'CALLS.
>> ALL I DO THIS. WANT TOIND T.
>> TME HE T ANCORRUPUNIT.
EXPERTISE COULD BE USEFUL.
SHE'INOPLE LIKE
MIKE CARLSON WHO'S APERT IN
S OF EVIDENCE. A GUYAMN FLOYD,
HE'S COMINCONTRACT
N
CKALLY COMPLEX CASESINVESTE CH
BRING. ALSO LITERALLY WROTE THEK
ON RACKETEERING RGIA.
THIS IS ON THE FEW FOLKS
WHO' THE PUBLIC INTEGRITY
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IF WILLIS
DECI, THIS I
T HE HAD S A FORMER AANTA
P VESTIG.IS IS F SOME  IN HIS T
SHE'S BUILDING WITAN
ATLANTA.RUPTION CASES IN
>>WITH YOUR EXPERTISE COVERING A
MEAN FOR TRUMP FOR WHAT HE COULD
FA
>> SHE SENT THOSE LETTERS TO
OFFICIALS IN THETEF ORGIA BEEVE
AND CONSPIRACY A RACKETEERING.
ESME RUNS ANPER EASY FOR HER TO
WHEN U TA ABOUT A
RACKETEERI
OVERTURN THE ELECTION INFO THEE
>> THANKOU. TO BRING IN M
WH
YOU HEAR ABOUT
SPIES THHEN
COUNUILDING.
>> THETRICT ATTORNHO
IRLY NEWLY BEETH, SHE' HOUSE
SHS T INR POWER
GROUP OF ATTORNEYS.L JUMPS OUT Y
IRING S
RACKETEERING EXPERT.
LAW A POWERFUL
TOOL FOR PS    PROSECUTORS.
RGANIZEDRO PERSO
TW ALE CRIMES AND COORDINATED
FOE. ME THEY'RE LOOKING AT AHE>H
CHARGES, BECOMING MORE
YEP CONTINUES TO R THE WO SEE
HET THE BIG
LIE.
WND HE TOOK THE
MINE AT MAR-A-LAGO TO TALK
ABOUT IT.
TMZ GOT THVIE SHOW
IT.
>> THEY SAID "66 MILLION VOTES
SIR AND THONOVER."
1P AND THEY SAID IT
IS S.
WHY ARE THEY CLOSING UP IN
CERTAIN PLACES?ARE HAPPENING
I WANT TO SAY ITO
BE HERANONOR TO HAVE Y
M-LCOUPLE.EWS ELECTION
HAPPENS.
>> I MEA
DONALD TRUMP IIB
TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FORHAT
HE'S DONE IN
THE DAMAGEDONE TO
DEMOCRACY IS MUCH MORE LASTING
THIS COUNT LEAST A THI
WHO                            D
ABOUT THE FRAUD OF ELECTION
D  STATE SLATURES AROUN
TOMETHING ABOUT THE
FRAUD WHICH DOES NOT.
DONALD TRUMP,  HIS OWNRA
CELEBRITY AND WHATEVER
TO DO AT WEDDIS
INCREDIBLE '
MO
>>E THE GOODS TO THCR
PROBE.
THENHAT DOES IT MEAN T
OTHER EN T
THEY ARE R
ISSUE E AT THE
THINGS.
THIS IS WHERE INL GET
INTERESTING.
IF A PERSON GETSPOENA THEY
W CHOICES.
TESTIFY UNDER OATH AND TWO, TAKE
THN MAOMAG TOR
MAY SHOW UHOUS S. MARSHA
KE YOU IN HANDCUFFS.
FAITH THIS DISTRICT ATTORNEY IS
THE CRIME FTITIO
ELECTIAL
A CRIMINAL CHARG PROVE
WOULD RESULT IPRISON TIME.
>> YESTHIS PCRIME
NITHREE YEARS.
IT WOULD BE A FELONY.
E SOMEONE  FELOND NOT GO PE.THE
AY BELIEVE'S
BIG LIE BUIT
IALS IN OOUP TO.
REPUBLICAN
MPF AT
OF  C
LAUNCHED THIS WHOLE PROBE INEAD
VOTED AND SOT'G.
AT. MATTHEW, GEORGI
S PASSED THAT ALLOWED
E DR BESD
THE GOVEHA
THEM.
WHAT  O YOU MAKE OF
METROP
MESSAGING.
IS GREAT THAT EY
UP TO DONALDRUT THE .
PEDIMENTS.E JIM CROW LAW THAT WS
WERE LEGAL.
IT SEEMS TO MEHA
DOING IN GEORGIA IS WEL
LAW BYWHEN YOU DO
THPASS AMAKE WHAT